when I'm tell their crazy so here at
sport Bible we like to test out these
drivers artistic ability we want him to
design a helmet but we couldn't find a
plain one so we've got the next best
thing
Asahara for Cindy a super fan and he sat
right there you've got one minute one
the timer's on my go start now the
teamwork is sensational the accuracy I
can see already is second to none
what we going on the top of the head is
a Mexican flag I will be judging we've
got ten seconds ten nine eight seven six
five four three two one and stop
so guys we're here judging the bald head
helmet during competition check first
about how was it I would not wear that
helmet really difficult to put painted
you know he was fed too much we had some
difficulty with the fire these are the
things that happen in the world of f1
I'm gonna give that out of 10 a 7.5 he
was a fantastic effort thank you
congratulation guys I wish then how did
you get here how did you get that drop I
don't know why I'm here how I'm here
you've been sensational thank you thank
you and thank you to our Sahara Force
India super fan
[Music]